esta vez vamos a trabajar con la
siguiente ecuación radical me voy a
tomar la ecuación raíz cuadrada de 3x
menos 7 ya esto le voy a sumar la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 2x menos 12
x menos 1 y esto lo voy a hacer igual a
0 y como siempre te invito a que pause
el vídeo y vea si puedes resolver para x
antes claro de que lo resolvamos juntos
ok pues vamos a resolverlo algo que
podemos intentar es bueno se me ocurre
pasar esta raíz cuadrada este radical
del lado derecho para así aislar los
radicales en un lado de la ecuación
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es restar
vamos a restar tanto del lado izquierdo
como del lado derecho la raíz de 2 x
menos 1 y voy a hacer lo mismo aquí voy
a restar la raíz de 2 x menos 1 lo estoy
restando del lado derecho del lado
izquierdo y que voy a obtener bueno del
lado izquierdo voy a obtener estos dos
se van y solamente me quedo con la raíz
con la raíz de 3x menos 7 muy bien y del
lado derecho bueno del lado derecho
solamente me quedo con menos la raíz de
2 x menos 1
x menos 1 y ahora podemos elevar al
cuadrado a ambos lados de la ecuación lo
voy a elevar al cuadrado pero siempre
hay que ser cuidadosos porque del lado
derecho de la ecuación de este lado
tenemos un signo negativo y recuerda que
cuando nosotros elevamos al cuadrado una
raíz cuadrada sea positiva o sea
negativa vamos a obtener el mismo valor
entonces al final cuando obtengamos una
solución esta podría ser la versión del
caso de haber resuelto la raíz cuadrada
en este caso negativa o en este caso
positiva no de la versión que nosotros
queríamos por lo tanto siempre que
tengamos nuestras soluciones al final
hay que verificar para asegurarnos que
son válidas para nuestra ecuación
original vamos a elevar eso al cuadrado
y vamos a ver que nos resulta el final
ahora bien si le vas al cuadrado de
ambos lados de la ecuación del lado
izquierdo que vas a obtener bueno pues
vas a obtener simplemente
x 73 x 7 y del lado derecho que vas a
obtener bueno del lado derecho este
signo negativo al elevarlo al cuadrado
se vuelve positivo y solamente te va a
quedar 2 x menos 12 x menos 1 ahora en
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí que te
parece si restamos 2x para dejar las x
solamente de un lado de la ecuación voy
a restar 2x y de este lado también voy a
restar 2x lo que soy intentando es que
estos dos se vayan y bueno qué te parece
si sumamos 7 de ambos lados de la
ecuación intentando que estos dos se
vayan y también de este lado voy a sumar
7 y con que me voy a quedar bueno veamos
del lado izquierdo tengo 3 x menos 2 x
bueno eso es simplemente x mientras que
del lado derecho me va a quedar menos 17
lo cual es 6 bueno ya que tenemos esto
que te parece si nosotros metemos
este valor en la ecuación original para
ver si realmente funciona vamos a checar
si ésta nos sirve y para eso voy a
sustituir acá arriba me va a quedar la
raíz de 3 que multiplica a 6 esto menos
7 muy bien ya esto le voy a sumar la
raíz de 2 que multiplica a 6 y esto
menos 1 y esto tiene que ser igual a
cero veamos 3 por 6 6 18 18 menos 7 es
11 entonces me va a quedar la raíz
cuadrada de 11 más y de este lado
también tengo la raíz cuadrada de 11 la
raíz cuadrada de 11 y esto tiene que ser
igual a 0 pero obviamente esto no es
cero
si sumas la raíz cuadrada de 11 con la
raíz cuadrada de 11 te da dos veces la
raíz cuadrada de 11 lo cual no
pero entonces esta solución parece que
no sirve para nuestra ecuación y
seguramente te estás preguntando cómo
sucedió que esta no es mi respuesta
correcta y sé toda esta clara y bonita
álgebra para llegar a algo que nos sirve
que fue lo que sucedió y bueno lo que
pasó es que aquí tenemos una solución
extraña porque una solución extraña
bueno porque esta es la solución de la
ecuación la raíz de 3x menos 7
menos la raíz de 2 x menos 1 y esto
igual a 0 y también te vas a preguntar
bueno porque obtengo la solución de esta
ecuación radical y no de la que yo
buscaba que paso si hice todas las
operaciones que break as que yo buscaba
aquí y bueno la clave es que cuando
pasamos este término del lado derecho y
después lo elevamos al cuadrado voy a
regresar de nuevo a este paso que tengo
aquí todo se reduce a este paso que
tengo aquí exactamente el mismo
independientemente del punto donde
empecemos obtuvimos exactamente lo mismo
que hubiéramos obtenido con esta
ecuación radical entonces la solución de
esto termino siendo la solución de esta
que tenemos aquí cambiamos de punto de
inicio aquí empezamos con esta ecuación
de rosa cuando realmente queríamos
empezar con esta ecuación de color café
y bueno esta es una manera interesante
de pensar todo esto pero más aún
la ecuación de café no tiene soluciones
y sería divertido pensar porque no tiene
soluciones ojo observa que mostramos en
cierto grado que la única solución que
obtienes al hacer todos estos pasos
razonables de álgebra es una solución
extraña es una solución de una ecuación
distinta la cual bueno claro tiene pasos
intermedios comunes pero también es
divertido que pienses porque este de
aquí es imposible que tenga soluciones